توفيت المغنية ليزا ماري بريسلي
الابنة الوحيدة للراحل إلفيس بريسلي
وبريسيلا بريسلي يوم الخميس عن عمر يناهز 54 عامًا.
وأكدت والدتها الوفاة
في بيان لشبكة سي إن إن.
ليزا ماري إنهم
ممتنون للغاية لدعم
الحب والصلوات من الجميع ويطلبون
الخصوصية خلال هذا الوقت الصعب للغاية ،
تم إدخال ليزا ماري بريسلي إلى المستشفى
صباح الخميس بعد معاناتها من توقف
القلب ، ولدت بريسلي
في عام 1968 في ذروة شهرة والدها.
توفيت في عام 1977 عندما كانت في
التاسعة من عمرها فقط ، كانت لديها
طفولة مضطربة أدت إلى تمثيلها
وتجربتها للمخدرات ، مما أدى إلى قيام
والدتها بإرسالها إلى سلسلة من
المدارس الخاصة التي أخبرت لوس أنجلوس تايمز أنني
لم ألتحق بها حقًا في المدرسة.  لم يكن
لديها حقًا أي اتجاه ، فقد عاشت وريثة روح
والدها ليزا ماري
ويسلي حياة ملونة في نظر
الجمهور كثيرًا  مما أدى إلى لحظات
في صحف التابلويد
كانت تقريبًا خشنة تزوجت أربع
مرات بما في ذلك الزيجات رفيعة المستوى
مع الممثل نيكولاس كيج وحفل زفاف
مع ملك البوب ​​مايكل جاكسون
الذي احتل كل العناوين الرئيسية التي
طلقوها في يناير 1996. في وقت لاحق في  في
مقابلة أجريت عام 2003 مع ديان سوير بريسلي ،
قال هذا عن جاكسون عندما
يريد أن يحبسك ويريد أن
يثيرك أو يأسرك أو تعرف ما
يريد أن يفعله معك ، يمكنه أن يفعل ذلك ،
أنجبت بريسلي أربعة أطفال من اثنين من
أربعة  زواج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سجلت ثلاثة ألبومات استوديو
خاصة بها في عام 2003 ، وصل ألبومها الأول To Who It
May Concern إلى المرتبة الخامسة على
لوحة الإعلانات 200 وحصلت على شهادة ذهبية في
ذلك الصيف
، وقالت هذا عن توليها نفس
المهنة مثل أسطوريتها  يا أبي ، أعتقد أنني
كنت أكثر سذاجة قليلاً على هذه الجبهة
مما يتوقعه المرء أنني كنت من
محبي الموسيقى الضخمين ، فقد كان له دائمًا تأثير كبير
علي أريد أن أكتب أريد أن
أغني أريد أن أغني  نفس الشيء بالنسبة
للآخرين
، أتمنى أن تفعل موسيقاي ذلك
للآخرين يومًا ما دون أن تدرك أنك تعرف
ما الذي يجب أن أدعيه نوعًا ما كان لدي
فكرة قليلاً ، لكنني أعتقد أنني في
ظل تقديري لمأساة تبعت
بريسلي في عام 2020  توفي ابن بنيامين
كيو منتحرًا عن عمر يناهز 27 عامًا. في
سبتمبر الماضي ، انفتحت عن
حزن تلك الخسارة في مقال
بمناسبة يوم التوعية بالحزن الوطني ،
شوهدت بريسلي مؤخرًا
ليلة الثلاثاء في حفل توزيع جوائز غولدن غلوب
الذي حضرته معها.
سئلت الأم لدعم فيلم Baslerman Elvis عن
والدها الراحل ليزا عن
الفيلم على السجادة الذي
كنت أتخيله حقًا ، كان علي
أن أستغرق حوالي خمسة أيام لمعالجته
لأنه كان موضعيًا وأصليًا للغاية
أوستن بتلر الذي لعب دور إلفيس  في
الفيلم تحدثت عن لقاء ليزا ماري ،
ضرب المنزل عندما قابلت ليزا موراي لأول مرة
لأنني لم أقابلها إلا
بعد الفيلم وعانقتني
والدموع في عينيها واه وقد قالت فقط
شكرًا لك  ou